[Music]
[Music]
when there were early discussions of if
the elena was going to come back i did
not see it coming that they were going
to put me and clint against each other
which i thought was a really cool twist
someone is hired the black widow
assassin is gotten very real very
quickly
elena is such an amazing character and
her and kate have quite a lot of fun
together get bishop
hi
i made macaroni if you want some it's
really tasty really tasty yeah i know
what box mac and cheese tastes like okay
i know it's it's delicious bringing
someone like florence it really brings
in an interesting dynamic with kate like
i think that was what was really fun was
actually to see how these two characters
click to see natasha romanov's sister
sitting talking to clint barton's
prodigy we just sat back and really
enjoyed it i love american christmas is
the tree this super-powered reindeer
have you ever eaten reindeer cannot say
i've had the pleasure no it is not a
pleasure it's really tough it's chewy
when we finished black widow my whole
experience was with scarlett and she
really welcomed me into the mcu and then
to jump into her scene partners world
was just as sweet it's been a really
good first two years in the mcu
you